Let's say we wanted to figure
out the equilibrium constant
for the reaction boron
trifluoride in the gaseous
plus 3-- so for every mole of
this, we're going to have 3
moles of H2O in the liquid
state-- and that's in
equilibrium.
It's going forward and backwards
with 3 moles of
hydrofluoric acid, so it's
in the aqueous state.
It's been dissolved
in the water.
If it wasn't dissolved, if it
was in the solid state, you
would call this hydrogen
fluoride.
Once it's in water, you call
it hydrofluoric acid, and
we'll talk more about naming
in the future, hopefully.
Plus 1 mole of boric acid, also
in the aqueous state.
It's dissolved in the water.
H3BO3 in the aqueous state.
So what would the expression for
the equilibrium constant
look like in this situation?
So you might be tempted say, OK,
that's easy enough, Sal.
So the equilibrium constant,
you just take
the right-hand side.
That's just the convention.
There's symmetry here.
I could've rewritten it either
way, but let's just say you
take the right-hand side and
say, OK, this is dependent on
the concentration of the
hydrofluoric acid, the
concentration of the HF, or the
molarity of the HF, to the
third power, times the
concentration of the boric
acid, H3BO3.
And remember, this intuition of
why you're taking this to
the third power is what's the
probability-- because in order
for the reaction to go this
way, you need to have 3
molecules of hydrofluoric acid
being very close to 1 molecule
of the boric acid.
So if you watched the last video
I just made about the
intuition behind the equilibrium
constant, this is
indicative of the probability of
this reaction happening or
the probability of finding
all of these
molecules in the same place.
Of course, you can adjust it
with a constant and that's
essentially what that does.
But that's on the product
side, or the reactant,
depending on what direction
you're viewing this equation,
divided by the molarity of the
boron trifluoride times-- and
I'll do this in a different
color-- the molarity of the
H2O to the third power.
And that's, of course,
the H2O liquid.
So there you go.
We'll just figure this out.
And my rebuttal to you is I
want you to figure out the
molarity of the water.
What is the concentration
of the water?
Remember, the concentration is
moles per volume, but in this
case, what's happening?
I'm putting some boron
trifluoride gas essentially
into some water, and it's
creating these aqueous acids.
These other molecules
are dissolved
completely in the water.
So what's the solvent here?
The solvent is H2O.
This might be how the reaction
happens, but pretty much,
there's water everywhere.
The water is in surplus.
So if you were to really figure
out the concentration
of water, it's everywhere.
I mean, you could say everything
but the boron
trifluoride, but it's
a very high number.
And if you think about it from
the probability point of view,
if you say, OK, in order for
this reaction to happen
forward, I need to figure out
the probability of finding a
boron trifluoride atom or
molecule-- actually,
molecule-- in a certain volume,
and it also needs 3
moles of water in that
certain volume.
But you say, hey, there's
water everywhere.
This is the solvent.
There's water everywhere, so
I really just need to worry
about the concentration of
the boron trifluoride.
So you could say the forward
reaction rate, rate forward,
is going to be dependent on some
forward constant times
just the concentration of
the boron trifluoride.
The water's everywhere, so you
don't have to multiply it
times the concentration of
water, whatever that means,
because the water's
everywhere.
So the denominator here, you
do not put the solvent.
So the correct answer for this
one is you only put whatever
is actually dissolved
in the solution.
Because frankly, the
concentration doesn't actually
makes sense for everything else,
and if you think about
it from the probability point
of view, that also makes
sense, because there's
always water around.
If you said, OK, what's the
probability of finding water
at any small volume of our
fluid, it's going to be 1, so
you could just multiply it by
a 1 there, but that doesn't
make a difference.
Now, what about the following
reaction?
Any equilibrium where you have
different states of matter is
called a heterogeneous
equilibrium.
And so let me write another
heterogeneous equilibrium.
So let's say I have H2O in the
gaseous state and that's
essentially steam-- so it's not
going to be the solvent
this time-- plus carbon
in the solid state.
And let's say that that's an
equilibrium with hydrogen in
the gas state plus carbon
dioxide in the gaseous state.
This is a heterogeneous
equilibrium because you have
things in the gaseous
and the solid state.
And solid state, by definition,
it can't be
dissolved either into the gas
or into the-- when we talk
about solutions, we talked about
colloids and suspensions
and mixtures before, but we're
talking about solutions.
By definition, if this
is in the solid
state, it's not dissolved.
If this was dissolved, we
would write an aq here.
It would be the aqueous state.
So if you talk about the forward
reaction, what's the
forward reaction going
to be dependent on?
So the rate forward, well, the
solid, there's a big block of
carbon sitting there.
There's a big cube of carbon
there, and there's steam,
there's water gas
all around it.
So if you pick any volume,
especially if you pick some
volume near the boundary of
the carbon, you're always
going to have carbon around.
It's just what matters
is the concentration
of the water gas.
That's what's going to drive
the forward rate, so the
forward rate is going to be
dependent on some constant
times the concentration
of the water gas.
And, of course, the backwards
rate, so you need to get some
H2, some molecules of-- let me
draw it like that, because it
has 2 hydrogen molecules plus
a carbon dioxide, so maybe a
carbon dioxide looks
like that.
So the reverse reaction, so
rate, let's call that reverse,
is going to be equal to some
constant times the probability
of finding both of these
molecules in the same place.
And, of course, the probability
is related to or
it's on a first-level
approximation, depending on
the concentration.
So it's concentration of H2
times the concentration-- and
to find both of them, you
multiply the probability,
because you need this
and that-- times the
concentration of CO.
So when a reaction is in
equilibrium, these two equal
each other-- this is an r right
here-- so this is going
to be equal to the reverse
rate of reaction H2 times
carbon dioxide.
Divide both sides by the K's,
both sides by the H2O, and you
get the forward coefficient or
constant or whatever you want
to call that, divided by the
reverse constant-- I'm just
dividing both sides by that-- is
equal to this-- let me just
copy and paste that-- is equal
to that divided by this.
You take that and you
divide it by that.
And so if we call this the
equilibrium constant, because
it's just two arbitrary
constants, so we can just call
this the equilibrium constant,
you see that it actually makes
a lot of sense to ignore
the solid state in your
equilibrium reaction.
So the two takeaways here
is when you're trying to
calculate an equilibrium
constant, you should ignore--
especially when it's in a
heterogeneous equilibrium--
you should ignore the
solution-- or not the solution.
Ignore the solvent in that first
example, where I did it
with boron trifluoride
with water.
Water was the solvent,
so I ignored it.
Because water is everywhere,
and you also
ignore the solid state.
Ignore the solid.
Anyway, we'll probably use these
in future things where
we actually calculate the
equilibrium constant.
See you in the next video where
we'll learn about Le
Chatelier's principle.